hi
i'm susan adino welcome to limbs for the
cannabis laboratory
um in actually the cannabis industry
from seed to sale
of course that includes the laboratory
thank you for being here today i look
forward to sharing some really great
information with you about limbs
cloud limbs in particular as a dynamic
system it's a wonderful approach and a
wonderful addition to the industry
so my only regret is that we're not here
in person
and i'm trusting everybody as well and
healthy and safe
and with that i will get started
so what exactly is seed to sales
software
well for a lack of
anything more substantive it really is
see-to-sale
um accounting it's a it's a tracking
ability that tracks the entire life of
the cannabis
product from the time it's grown all the
way to the time it's sold to the
customers and who knows in the future it
could also include the
the degradation or the this final
disposition of that product as it is
trashed so why bother with the see to
sales software
i think that it is extremely helpful
to any kind of a cannabis business to
manage the inventory
and comply with a lot of the state and
local regulatory
uh requirements and guidelines
so as you know the cannabis industry is
not exactly straightforward it is not
always easy and sometimes there are
competing
processes in place so what the software
is going to allow you to do
is to manage all of that with a little
less anxiety
greater ease and more accountability so
there are a lot of features that are
involved in all of this
and ultimately you can pick and choose
which features you like
so what we're going to talk about today
are some of those features
some of the retail processes and
software that's available to you
that will likely help you in your your
piece of the industry
so let's start off with what are the
stages of the seed to sail life cycle
obviously i think it begins with
cultivation
and then we are harvesting and then we
are we are testing that
and of course transportation and
transportation actually happens in a
couple of places
here in many states it happens between
harvest
and testing and in other places then it
also includes
testing and then transportation and then
point-of-sale
ultimately patients have access to this
and patient identification and
verification and then finally it ends up
in a real-time
data portal so this is a very
broad overview what seed to sale
tracking
is and it's there to ensure compliance
and ultimately consumer safety
why is this important to us well i think
first and foremost many of the
regulators want to know what's going on
with that
with the cannabis product particularly
in that we're still living in a federal
prohibition of the substance
and so it provides an opportunity for
central control
and monitoring it also provides a single
database
one database that you can go into
and look at what's happening with that
particular product
so we have cultivators who can pop in we
have
processors who can pop in testing
laboratories
dispensaries you know i'll just kind of
pop in and see what's happening with
that product and how it's affected your
particular component of this industry
wherever your
services lie when we put all of those
pieces together we
end up with a comprehensive history and
timeline for
all things that have happened to that
cannabis product
or the cannabis that's been produced for
the
sale and ultimate consumption by the
public
so it really is a great great great way
to
track all of this and state regulators
are looking for this trackability they
want to know what's going on with this
product
and so you know in addition to that
there's also opportunity for each
individual component so the cultivator
the processor the consumer to know
what's happening with that product
again businesses need the software
that's going to offer a nice portal to
its consumer
is because its customer or its client
whether it's a cultivator
or manufacturer or perhaps testing
location gives everybody an opportunity
to share the results
and where we are gaining in efficiency
when we do this so we don't have to go
around and look for
previous testing or previous use and
figure out where all those pieces fall
it's a nice
great comprehensive system
for laboratories it allows the
laboratory to track what's going on
in their labs in their facilities what's
happened to their samples
how they tested what are those test
results
and then they can automatically upload
to
the third party regulatory database like
metric or
leaf or biotrack
these are all third-party databases that
are facilitated by
various state regulators and this is
where
customers will get the results of
testing results
it's where laboratories have to deliver
their test results to their customers
so this provides an interface between
the laboratory for example
and metric or laboratory and leave or
the cultivator and leaf
i mean you kind of get that now
we're also tracking the life cycle of
the products
again from planting that cultivation
part
all the way up to when the product is
sold
this provides the manager of the
business to
look at the supply chain from the
business perspective
and ensure that their practices and
processes are optimized
again it's a comprehensive picture of
what's happening
and we can isolate the information that
we need for each
individual business
or opportunity and maximize our
our our business plan
with respect to the cultivators they can
forecast the yield
we can look at tracking the genealogy of
a plant or
selection of plants um it's essentially
built for
growers here and it gives everybody an
opportunity to analyze those results
again in a more comprehensive or
complete manner
so you very very um utilitarian function
here for cultivators
can you imagine having an opportunity to
create your cultivation plan your scheme
your your plants your seeds and
understand what's happening on a long
term basis
well cloud limbs gives you that
opportunity to do that
with respect to seed to sale tracking
again it addresses the needs of the
cannabis labs the testing labs
in responding to both the state and
local governments
and with respect to hemp it also brings
in the federal government as we know
hemp is regulated by the usda and
certainly this would be incorporated in
that
with respect to the cannabis testing in
particular
my goodness as we know many cannabis
laboratories are required to be
iso 17025 accredited
well a lot of this speaks to some of
that so maybe this will sound familiar
to you
in the cannabis laboratory we need to
manage qc samples and their results
and remember that quality control
samples
are there to ensure that the results of
our testing
are adequate correct consistent
and that they are ready to be released
to the
customer we can't release any data
unless we know that
our system of analysis on that
particular day for that particular batch
has been successful and qc is sort of
the gate post for that
we also have document control
requirements so
there are many documents that exist in a
laboratory
everything from working instructions
to standard operating procedures to
instrument manufacture requirements for
maintaining instruments
there are many documents it can run into
the hundreds or be down into
you know 10 or 20 documents but
ultimately no laboratory can function
without a series of documents to support
the quality management system
very easily these documents get a little
out of control quite honestly
so either they're updated or we have new
staff coming in
and we have to make sure that everybody
is aware of what's going on
um when documents are issued or when
they're updated
so very often in a non-lens environment
we see a flurry of paper all over the
lab
limbs can also help the cast testing lab
with uh staff training so
staff training again happens every day
all over the place and we need records
of all of that
so liz can not only manage those records
but they can also help
us to identify the track
the training needs that are upcoming and
current
and so again many applications
with that we have chain of custody
results so chain of custody for many
labs
begins at the cultivation facility where
the laboratory has to go out and perform
the sampling
then they bring that sample back to the
laboratory and then the laboratory tests
the sample
in other cases the labs are not required
to do that testing
or i'm sorry are not required to do that
sampling and they only test the sample
that the customer delivers
at the laboratory so there's a lot that
goes on with that chain of custody
part of it involves a contract part of
it
involves an agreement with a customer or
an agreement between the lab and the
customer to perform specific work
so there's a lot that goes on and that
chain of custody is necessary
for continuity of services as well as
for defensibility
legal defensibility the lab isn't fairly
not
able to perform work on a customer
sample unless we know the history of
that sample
instrument calibration and maintenance
can also be
tracked and kept up current current
speed
with lens and again we're coming
full circle here to the qc in validating
tests
test results we're coming back to what
is
what processes do we have in place in
the laboratory
to empirically justify the data that we
are producing
that we are ultimately sending back out
to the laboratory to the customer
the laboratory's customers so that
validation process
can be very complex and it can be
somewhat circuitous
at times quite frankly there's a lot
that goes on with that
and a lot of times laboratories are
encumbered by hiring
extra personnel to check that
test results and validating the
individual results before they go out
so there's a lot that goes into running
a laboratory and generating a test
result
and lens here can certainly help
laboratory on any number of these in any
number of these places on any number of
levels
so let's talk about where some of this
is brought up in 17025
and in particular the 2017 revision
well qc samples in their results is
in response to iso 17025 clause number
7.7
right 8.3
is the area or the clause that specifies
document control that no documents can
be used
were issued unless they have been
authorized are appropriate and that all
old documents have been removed from
places of use
so not only is the laboratory
responsible for
updating documents when they're
necessary so updating an sop
they also have to make sure that the
previous revisions have been removed
from the laboratory
when we're working with paper documents
this becomes a very
challenging task and
in order to be compliant with section
8.3
of 1705 we need something to ensure
that our documents are very well
controlled
that people have only the documents that
they need to perform their jobs
section 6.2 or clause 6.2 of iso 17025
is specific to staff training there are
many
requirements for staff training in this
new revision
of the standard and it's quite honestly
really been bumped up from the previous
revision iso revision
so a lot goes into staff training it's
not just about
hiring people and training them to
perform their job
it's also making sure that they are
competent
and proficient to perform anything
any function that affects that test
result
anything that goes into the performance
of
testing it also requires staff training
and authorization to be monitored on an
ongoing basis so not only are we
training new people we are
ensuring that they're still competent
some period of time
later could be months later a year later
two years later
but that monitoring has to show up in
records
and 6.2 is the direction for all of that
and lens certainly makes short work of
that
in terms of scheduling and
follow-through
7.4 of the of the standard is
includes uh chain of custody it includes
the fact that
all test items must be handled
appropriately
and that we have to understand the
history of that because
of that sample when did we first put our
hands on it
when did we get it into the lab what did
we do do it
so 7.4 ensures
that the laboratory can defend and has
justification for handling
all testament all test materials
appropriately
chain of custody is certainly part of
that
clause 6.4 of the standard calls
out the instrument calibration and
maintenance
so again we in order to do good work in
the laboratory
need to ensure that our instruments are
working properly that they are properly
maintained and
calibrated in a non-limbs environment
this again becomes
a paper nightmare so bringing it all
together here through cloud limbs
we're able to assimilate and spend
more time looking at the bigger picture
of what's happening
in our laboratory rather than chasing
paper
and finally ensuring test results we're
really talking about
section 7.8 of the standard there are
many requirements that go
into reporting a test result
and ensuring that what goes on the coa
is
complete it's accurate and that it's
defensible
and so limbs is able to
bring together all of these elements and
pretty much
automate most of that for us it
certainly
does improve our opportunity in the
laboratory to spend our time
in the laboratory looking at data and
not necessarily
checking all the boxes before we issue
the coa with proper programming
and betting cloud blends will take care
of a good number of
these responsibilities for us that are
again
requirements of 17025
so how does it manage qc test results
well
one way that it manages this is to
have an automatic upload of the qc
results
and we flag it with error bars or
confidence intervals
and so limbs will tell us when we are
outside that comfort zone or outside
that
that confidence zone where we need to
then stop
the issuance of the test result and back
up and try to understand what's going on
and this is an enormous help in a
laboratory
because if the limbs
with the lens is evaluating the data for
us we can
again take personnel away and
improve the laboratory efficiency now it
doesn't mean
laboratory personnel are exonerated from
dealing
with any kind of qc work that's
certainly not true
but lens will give us the opportunity
to flag the result and then
the personnel our chemists or scientists
can then back up and understand where
the breakdown happened
so again when we look at setting up
cloud limbs with the specification
limits that we need
we can build in decision roles and it
will automate that system
for us it will allow us to more
easily evaluate quality control and the
release
of test data
as it's doing this all of the qce data
are ending up
in a plot so we need to be able to
analyze
data in a way that we can detect trends
again this is another iso 17025
requirement
and by this automated plotting
again we set our own um
confidence limits and our warning limits
so we can say well
you know if we get data that's right
around here on a line
then we're still going to pass the test
result
but we want to look a little more
closely in this
and if something is beyond that and is
actually outside of specification zone
then we need to back up completely
so this trend analysis is an awesome
tool
why are we plotting the trend at all not
only is it giving us indication of
pass or fail as our qc
but ideally what it's doing is setting
up the
framework for us to project and forecast
a problem before it becomes a problem
if we notice that our qc continually
trend upward or downward maybe there's
an indication there that
something has gone awry and it will give
us an opportunity to back up
and look at what could potentially be
happening
before it goes out of compliance so
trend analysis
is hugely important in the laboratory
and cloud limbs is making that a very
accessible and easily used
feature
document control manages documents we're
tracking that revision history
we're assigning and accessing privileges
to the staff based on their roles
not every staff person needs to have
access to every
document that exists in the laboratory
if we have somebody who's just doing
field sampling and so his or her role is
only to go out to the field and do that
sampling
he or she doesn't necessarily need to
know how to
clean an icp ms so having access
to the maintenance requirements for the
icp
really is not necessary for that person
so this gives us an opportunity to
make available the documents that people
need to perform their jobs
and again as i mentioned earlier there's
a lot that goes into document control
it's not only issuing a new document but
it is also making sure that people have
access to the document that they need in
that all previous documents have been
redacted
this gives us an opportunity to
streamline everything and have assurance
and provide a record of when people are
reading the documents so we know
who's read what we also have a record of
what the most current document is
it makes document control a whole lot
easier than
manual manipulation
staff training and competency
as i mentioned training is a really huge
feature in 17025
i don't know about most laboratories or
your laboratory but many laboratories
are undergoing a rapid turnover rapid
turnover
and staffing so there are a lot of
people coming in a lot of people going
out
and also laboratories are growing
so what may have started with five or
six analysts or chemists
now may have 40 or 50 chemists
you know two years out so staff training
always becomes a challenge it is
um it could be a very big
problem for many laboratories not just
an initial training
but also in that monitoring remember
that
nobody can perform any work on a sample
on a customer sample
unless he or she is trained
and is determined competent and is
authorized to perform
very specific work that work affects
every function in the laboratory
from field sampling to preparing a
sample
to analyzing a result to issuing a coa
everything needs a demonstration
or some clarification on competency
and monitoring of that competency these
records have to be available
if they are not available or there is no
record
of training and competency then it
didn't happen
what cloud limbs does is gives us an
opportunity to streamline all of that
it is that management system for the
staff training
so we can in a moment's notice know
who's competent who needs training where
are we
and can we lock out a person from
performing a particular method
until he or she has been trained
and authorized to perform this very
specific function
again a great tool for managing training
and competency which is not a trivial
matter in any laboratory
chaining chain of custody from
sample collection to assessing a
sessioning
to disposal everything that that
sample has gone through needs to be
accounted for this is part of the chain
of custody
who is the customer when did we get that
sample did we go
and pick it up did was it dropped off at
the laboratory
how much of that sample did we use for
testing how much of it was disposed
where did we dispose it how did we
dispose it these are
all elements that regulatory bodies
expect from a laboratory and
lynn's cloud limbs gives us
that chain of custody accessibility and
trackability from the moment we see it
to the moment we get rid of it it's a
long chain
and being able to track every event in
in that chain is is essential to the
functioning of a laboratory
overall workflow management as we know
laboratories
are not simple processes we don't say
pick up this paper and go analyze the
sample
there are workflows involved there could
be
rush samples involved there could be
retest samples it could be a qc sample
failure we
have processes that are all governed
under the quality management
system of that is quality assurance
of that also under that quality
management system is quality control
all of this needs to be managed this
entire workflow
who's going to be doing the sample
preparation
on customer a sample who's going to be
performing the analytical work who's
going to analyze the data
where is that data being analyzed how is
it being uploaded
to a coa who's checking that coa how is
it being released to the third party
database
there's just a huge amount of work and
steps that we don't normally
think about that go into analyzing a
test sample
so this entire workflow is captured by
cloud lens again
it is tailor-made so the parameters
around all of this are up to the needs
of the laboratory
maybe your workflow only has five steps
maybe the lab across the street has 25
steps
we can modify this to meet your needs
instrument calibration and maintenance
all
instruments need to be qualified before
they are used
so as soon as an instrument is put into
service or brought into a laboratory
needs to be qualified
we need to make sure that it's qualified
we need to ensure that all equipment
balances
pipettes thermometers all of these
things are calibrated
and verified so calibration is generally
performed by an
external company a 17025 calibration
company
verifications are usually performed
in-house
and the verification is assurance that
the piece of equipment is still
operating within its boundaries within
its calibration boundaries so for
example if we get a balanced
calibrated and then we're getting it
calibrated every year we still check it
pretty much every day
if not every day using a set of
calibrated check weights to make sure
that the balance is operating
in that appropriate range for us again
a lot of data same thing with
thermometers so if we have a
refrigerator or
or a freezer where we're storing stuff
we need to ensure that the
environmental conditions are being met
so this gives us that opportunity to
capture that data
we also have instrument maintenance i
mentioned earlier icp
now we have icps we have
gcs we have lcs hplcs
we have a lot of really heavy duty
instrument
out there instrumentation available in
the laboratory
and we need to ensure that it's being
maintained
appropriately and by competent staff so
we need an opportunity
to capture all of this data we need to
manage this other workflow this is just
the
workflow within the workflow the
instrument calibration and maintenance
not only what is on the schedule was it
performed
was it performed correctly by competent
personnel
all of this needs to be captured in
order to be compliant
with 17025 and also quite frankly
for the laboratories that are not 17025
accredited
this helps you in your laboratory
because
you need to make sure that your
instruments are working what confidence
can your results have for your customers
if you're not using qualified
instrumentation
and be able to defend that with these
records
so cloud limbs gives you that
opportunity gives you the opportunity to
manage this other
micro workflow within the larger
workflow of the laboratory
ensuring test results so we can send out
multiple test results for review
and verification and validation and
approval
before the coa is actually released to
the customers
so again this is assimilating all the
data that's been brought into
the limbs right when i think about a
lens i think of a black box
and i think of tons of inputs and then
the
output is the coa so we look at all of
the input
we look at did qualified people run the
method
what method was run what documents did
they use
who was trained and authorized which
instruments did we use
how what data do we get and who is
evaluating that data
we check through all of that before the
final output goes out to the customer
and we know that as the coa so we're
ensuring the test results and we're
consolidating all of those individual
inputs into one centralized location
so cloud limbs is bringing in all of the
workflows
into this one area that the
qualified person maybe it's your cso
maybe it's your lab director it doesn't
really matter
who that person is as long as he or she
is qualified
can now look at all of the individual
inputs
and give the final approval to push
out that data onto that coa
that is headed for the customer so we
have an opportunity here to again
bring in all those workflows into
something that's very easily managed
generating the coa becomes
a very seamless method and practice for
the laboratory
again this is set up for your specific
laboratory
we put in your specifications we can
upload your decision rules um
and cloud limbs will say you know what
we may be the driver behind the coa but
this is
your coa the coa speaks to you
speaks to your laboratory we want to
make it as
easy for you as possible to get this
information out that is important for
your customer
so we're directing the coa
we're directing limbs to generate the
coa only on the information
on the data that is important to you and
to your customer
and it does it very easily we don't have
to deal with pdfs we don't have to deal
with excel sheets we're
we don't have to deal with so much that
we've been dealing with over the years
cloud limbs really makes it easy it
brings it all to one place
not only to push it out as a coa
but also to review it all and it makes
reading it a whole lot easier on the
other end
i have been with some customers who've
received this coa and
and they just think of dynamite because
whatever they need is there
so we have the portal how does it all
work well we have a client portal
so we can download upload the
as well as invoices so this goes beyond
where some other limbs stop
at the coa we can now use
the cloud limbs to generate the invoices
again the portal becomes a very
easy to manage tool consolidated tool
for your customers and also it's helping
your business decisions
it's helping you manage your business
operations you know who got what and
when
and when they were aware of their
invoice
we also have a read-only audit trail
so this becomes incredibly important
with iso 17025 and even beyond that for
the overall defensibility of the lab
we want things to be auditable we want
things to be
defensible we want to know what's going
on when
changes are made to the lens to our
specification limits when we're updating
stuff
we need to maintain an audit trail of
that
17025 requires an audit trail anytime
we've made any changes to limbs
cloud lymph makes that very easy there's
a date and time stamp
invisible read-only audit trail that is
available
whenever an update is made
crucial for the defensibility if any of
the laboratories activities are called
into question on a legal end
and crucial for
defending this to your iso
17025 assessor
instrument and software integration
again this is
cloud lens is bringing it all together
for us it is
managing a workflow within the bigger
workflow
so it's bringing together the instrument
and as we know instruments are driven by
software
right we have software drivers so
we are managing those software drivers
and when that software is updated
bringing it all together so that we can
now minimize the turnaround time
we are going to uh
be able to post results directly into
that seed to sale software
such as metric and leaf and biotrack thc
all of this is enhancing the
laboratory's efficiency
and defensibility i keep coming back to
the word
sensibility and i think that we all
agree
that we're seeing more and more lawsuits
come up or more labs
closing down because of failure to
comply with certain requirements
regulations some of that may be about
staff confidence or laboratory
competence and maybe some of it is about
record management and the integration
and the compilation
of all of the data that goes into this
maybe they didn't have that
i i honestly don't know but when i think
about
the future of our industry i see our
future
seeing more laboratories shut down and
more laboratory failure
so we need this integration we need this
integrative
integration process in the laboratory
to make sure that all that we're doing
is transparent
it's available it's defensible we need
this defensibility
benefits of deploying a cannabis limbs
and in particular are cloud limbs
we're going to improve our defensiveness
and verification
of test result accuracy we are most
definitely going to
improve our productivity quality
has many more checks and balances in
place that are a little more automated
and stop checks so that we can't go past
bar a if we haven't met those
requirements
and all of this is going to lead to
lower costs lower business costs
better business management and better
allocation of resources
quality management system overrides
everything
and this brings it all together for us
at the end of the day we end up with
better defensibility
better test results better quality and
lower costs that that efficiency
is paramount to the success of the
laboratory
siege sales software benefits for
manufacturers and
processors we have the conversion
tracking
we have transactional reports who's
doing what
who's getting what who's buying what
what is the process and of all of that
what's happening and what about the
transport manifests again we have two
points of transport
one is in many cases but not all
the laboratory going to the cultivation
facility to pick up the sample in the
first place and so we have
transport manifest number one to the
laboratory
but always we have transport manifest
to from the facility to the
dispensary being able to justify
and account for the transportation and
the actions and behavior of that product
are essential for regulatory bodies as
well as for the economy
of the product um for the distributor
right you want to know what's going on
where has it gone
so cloud limbs gives us that option
gives us that opportunity to bring it
all together
for the retailers we know what's going
on
we can look at purchase limits we look
at
managing the overall customer base
we have an automated data entry we know
who's buying what
you know where things are going how long
things are sitting on the shelf
or not sitting on the shelf we can also
use cloud lens to automate a discount
program
or a loyalty program
we can again bring all of this into an
easy reporting system
and again a more efficient way to
understand the business of
of um retail
so we have all of this in one one place
but how do you choose the right limbs
partner that's always the biggest
question isn't it
here's a checklist i'm not going to read
through everything on this checklist
it's here for you but you want to make
sure
that you can do everything that we've
talked about in the last 40 minutes or
so that you can maintain the chain of
custody that you know who touched that
sample
where it went how it got there when did
it get there
who then received it who did what to
that sample in a testing lab
what were those results who has access
to those results oh and by the way were
those results
validated and checked before they were
released are they good results
can we manage all of this together as
independent workflows and then as the
overall workflow
not all looms can do this cloudlines can
do this for you but i encourage you to
go
out and ask this big question how are
you going to choose
your partner i think we have in the last
40 minutes
certainly demonstrated the benefit
the essential benefit of having
limbs in the laboratory so now the next
question is
how are you going to choose the right
one for you and
is your lens partner able to provide
a tailor-made output for you or
tailor-made management workflow for you
those are the questions that you should
be asking yourselves
and i would like to say thank you very
much for being here today
um this has certainly been a pleasure to
talk about limbs and to talk about one
of my favorite subjects which is
laboratory science i encourage you to
reach out to
folks at cloud limbs for more
information or if you'd like
again a little more information from me
if i can help in any way
here's my contact information and i
invite you to contact me
by email or by phone and with that i
hope you are well
i hope that you enjoyed this
presentation and that it added value
to your business model and your business
decisions i look forward to working with
you in the future
thank you